RIGHT HERE, WE GUARANTEE A
CHEMICAL HE ALSO PROMISED TO
COVER THE AFTERMATH OF THE
DEBATE LAST NIGHT.
WE JUST TALKED ABOUT
KAMALA HARRIS.
SO FAR SHE'S GOT THEM PASS FROM
THE PRESS ON HER PRESIDENTIAL
RUN.
THEY WANT HER TO BE THE NEXT
PRESIDENT SO THEY ARE
OVERLOOKING HER BACK ON.
SHE WAS A FORMER PROSECUTOR, AS
YOU KNOW, BUT HER LEAD BRAND AS
A CRUSADER FOR PRISON REFORM.
NO ONE CALLED HER ON IT UNTIL
LAST NIGHT.
GROSSMAN TULSI GABBARD OF HAWAII
DEFINITELY CALLED HER ON IT.
WATCH THIS.
>> THERE ARE TOO MANY EXAMPLES
TO CITE BUT SHE PUT OVER 1500
PEOPLE IN JAIL FOR MARIJUANA
VIOLATIONS AND THEN LAUGHED
ABOUT IT WHEN SHE WAS AT THE
PANEL FOR MARIJUANA.
SHE BLOCKED EVIDENCE THAT WOULD
HAVE SCREENED AN INNOCENT MAN
FROM DEATH ROW UNTIL THE COURTS
FORCE HER TO DO JUST SO HE OR
SHE CAN PEOPLE IN PRISON BEYOND
THEIR SENTENCES TO USE THEM AS
CHEAP LABOR FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THERE IS NO REFUTE FOR THAT AND
THE PEOPLE WHO SUFFERED UNDER
YOUR RAIN IS PROSECUTOR, THEM AN
APOLOGY.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS AN
ELECTRIC MOMENT.
IT MIGHT BE WHY CONGRESSWOMAN
GABBERT WAS THE MOST GOOGLED
CANDIDATE SINCE THE DEBATE LAST
NIGHT.
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
CONGRESSWOMAN, THANKS A LOT FOR
COMING ON.
SO, I HAVEN'T HEARD ANYBODY SAY
WHAT YOU SAID.
WHY ARE YOU THE FIRST PERSON TO
SAY THIS?
>> LOOK, VOTERS DESERVE TO KNOW
THE TRUTH.
THE DECISION THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE BEFORE THEM IS A
CRITICAL ONE.
THE DECISION THAT THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE BEFORE THEM ABOUT WHO THEIR
NOMINEE SHOULD BE IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ONE.
THEY DESERVE TO KNOW THE TRUTH
ABOUT THE CANDIDATES THAT ARE
BEFORE THEM AND ESPECIALLY ON
THIS ISSUE OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM THAT'S IMPACTING SO MANY
PEOPLE ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
BECAUSE IT IS SO BROKEN AND IT
IS AN UNJUST CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS, WHO IS IN
A POSITION TO BE ABLE TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE, WHEN SHE WAS SERVING
AS ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AND AS I POINTED OUT LAST NIGHT,
SHE DID NOT FULFILL THAT PROMISE
THAT SHE CLAIMED TO HAVE, WHICH
IS TO BE A CHAMPION FOR THE
PEOPLE TO BE A CHAMPION FOR THE
OPPRESSED.
IN FACT, SHE DID THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
SHE MADE DECISIONS THAT ENDED UP
HURTING PEOPLE.
THAT ENDED UP HURTING
MINORITIES, HURTING POOR PEOPLE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
WHICH IS CONCERNING TO ME FOR
SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO BE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND FRANKLY, IS CLAIMING TO BE A
PROSECUTOR PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: I THINK, THIS IS A
REALLY INTERESTING DEBATE.
THIS TOPIC DESERVES A REAL
DEBATE.
YOU HAVE A PERSPECTIVE.
SHE HAS HER PERSPECTIVE.
IT WAS HEAR THEM BOTH.
SHE WOULD NOT ENGAGE WITH YOU
AND THAT'S WHAT I FOUND
CONTEMPTIBLE BUT ACTUALLY
FASCINATING.
SHE DISMISSED YOU AND HER
SPOKESMAN DISMISSED YOU EVEN
MORE SAVAGELY AS A PRUDENT
APOLOGIST.
WHAT YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS PREFER
SMALL, WHAT I WAS SHOWING WAS
NOT A MATTER OF OPINION PURE
THESE ARE WIDELY REPORTED FACTS
AND REPORTS ABOUT HER TENURE AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN CALIFORNIA.
HER CAREER AS A PROSECUTOR.
AND WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS, YOU
KNOW, 30 YEARS AGO OR 50 YEARS
AGO, THESE ARE THINGS THAT SHE
DID IN HER LAST JOB, JUST BEFORE
SHE WAS ELECTED AS U.S.
SENATOR AND SHE COULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEM.
SO, ANSWER FOR IT.
THE VOTERS DESERVE TO KNOW.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT, SHE REFUSED TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS, SHE
REFUSED TO ENGAGE ON THE DEBATE
STAGE, AND THE RESPONSES FROM
HER AND HER CAMPAIGN, AFTER THE
DEBATE, WAS BASICALLY TO LOBBY
CHEAP SMEARS AND BASICALLY SAY
THAT I AM A TRADER OR FOREIGN
AGENT TO ORDER TROJAN HORSE OR
WHATEVER WAS IN TRYING TO FEED
THOSE TALKING POINTS OF THE
MEDIA.
SO, YOU KNOW, THIS IS CONCERNING
ON MANY LEVELS ABOUT HOW
SENATOR HARRIS WOULD GOVERN AS
PRESIDENT.
THAT IF THERE ARE THOSE WHO ARE
CRITICS OF HER OR HER RECORD,
YOU KNOW, FOR ME, I AM TWO-TIME
VETERAN OF THE MIDDLE EAST
DEPLOYMENT.
I'M A SOLDIER, CURRENTLY STILL
SERVING IN THE ARMY.
I'M A SITTING MEMBER OF
CONGRESS, AND SHE IS SMEARING ME
IN THIS WAY.
IMAGINE WHAT SHE WOULD DO TO
ANYONE ELSE.
>> Tucker: IT'S A FAIR POINT.
THAT'S A FAIR POINT.
IT'S A REFUGE OF THE
CONTEMPTIBLE.
WHAT'D YOU THINK OF CNN'S
DEBATE?
THE WAY THAT THEY RAN IT?
WERE YOU SATISFIED WITH THAT?
>> I THINK IT HAD A LITTLE MORE
DECORUM THEN WE SAW IN THE FIRST
DEBATE.
BUT YOU KNOW, LOOK, I WISH THERE
WAS A MORE FAIR AND BALANCED
APPROACH IN HOW EVERY CANDIDATE
WOULD HAVE THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF
TIME TO ADDRESS THESE IMPORTANT
ISSUES THAT WE FACE.
THERE ARE MANY OF THEM, 60
SECONDS AND 30 SECONDS, SHORT
PERIODS OF TIME TO BE ABLE TO
DIG INTO THESE ISSUES.
SO THIS IS WHERE I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO BUILD THE SUPPORT FOR OUR
CAMPAIGN, TO MAKE IT FOR THE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR THE NEXT
DEBATE IN SEPTEMBER AND OCTOBER.
>> Tucker: THE ONE PLACE YOU
DON'T WANT TO BE IN WASHINGTON
IS OUTSIDE THE STATUS QUO, AS
YOU ARE.
THAT'S WHEN YOU START GETTING IT
FROM ALL SIDES.
>> THIS IS --
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATION AROUND THIS AND THE
THINGS THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT, AGAIN, REALLY COME DOWN
TO VALUING THIS ROLE, THIS JOB
AS PRESIDENT, AND THAT MOST
RESPONSIBILITY OF
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF AND
APPRECIATING THE FREEDOMS THAT
WE HOLD DEAR IN THIS COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW, IF I HAD THE HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS
PRESIDENT PRESIDENT, I CAN
GUARANTEE YOU THAT IF THERE ARE
CRITICS TO MY RECORD OR PEOPLE
WHO DISAGREE WITH MY POLICIES, I
WHO DISAGREE WITH MY POLICIES, A
WHO DISAGREE WITH MY POLICIES, M
WHO DISAGREE WITH MY POLICIES, N
WHO DISAGREE WITH MY POLICIES, T
GOING TO LABEL THEM AS FOREIGN
AGENTS OR TRADERS.
HAVING THIS VIGOROUS DEBATE IS A
PART OF WHO WE ARE AS A COUNTRY
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
GOT TO APPRECIATE AND ACTUALLY
HONOR THE VOTERS AND THE PEOPLE
OF THIS COUNTRY AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING THEM WITH
THE TRUTH AND THE INFORMATION